[Musique]
le jourg est arrivé tout le monde est
sur le pont pour voir venir le camion de
fret qui transporte les caisses qui
contiennent les œuvres en provenance de
la Johannesbourg art galerie plusieurs
heures ont été nécessaires pour faire
entrer ces œuvres sur le territoire
réunionné mais les caisses sont belles
et bien là deux petites caisses perdues
au fond du camignon qui contiennent de
véritables trésors ça
passe on va emmener les deux caisses dev
vent tout de suite
le moment tattendu est donc arrivé les
premières estampes apparaissent
fébrilement après un voyage de plusieurs
heures on peut enfin souffler et surtout
s'extasier devant autant de
beautés
cross
cross only il y a que deux lthographies
de crro cross qui existe enfin dans sa
production il a fait la peinture mais il
n'a fait que deux lithographies en voilà
et l'autre est exposé donc au musée
landiax jusqu'au mois Ju on verra les
deux seules lthographies de Croc qui
existent au monde des dessins des
peintures RAR qui rajoute à la qualité
des œuvres qui seront présentées pour
cette exposition croisée entre le fond
de la Johanesburg art galerie et celui
du musée leandier Mané Picasso Renoir ou
encore Toulouse l'autreg on a une série
de lithographie de Toulouse l'Autrec qui
est exceptionnelle qui compte parmi les
grands grands chefdœuvres de
toulousutreg quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Edmond cross qui est un peintre des
années 1890 1900 il a fait que deux
estampes au monde il n fait que deux
lithographies et nous avons à l'occasion
de cette exposition les deux
lthographies une appartenant au
musanders l'autre appartenant à la JAAC
on a également des des gravures sur bois
de valoton qui va renouveler le le le le
g de la gravure sur le bois à la fin du
19e siècle bref on a aussi des
lthographies de Renoir on a des
l'thographie C Rousell bref tout tout le
meilleur de la production desestant de
la fin du e siècle et du début du 20e
siècle est présent aujourd'hui au
muséeantierx il y a des séries
magistrales d''estamp d'Odilon Redon et
venant de la qui sont ici au musée
leonderx mais venant de la jag on a un
très bel ensemble de toulosotreg dont
l'album l qui n'a pas
été édité par Volard mais qui était
édité dans la même période à la fin du
19e siècle on a ainsi en croisant la
production soutenu par Volard et par les
autres galeristes ou imprimeurs de la
place de Paris les grands art de la fin
du siècle sous la forme qui était
supposée être la plus diffusable puisque
c sont des multiples les estemple chaque
œuvre devra être vérifiée une à une pour
contrôler leur état et surtout constater
qu'elles sont toutes bien arrivées
Vivien le régisseur d'œuvre du musée
pourra alors entrer en
[Musique]
scène